hi there today we'll look at
object-centric learning with slot
attention
by francesco locatello thomas kipf and
others of google brain
eth zurich and mpi on a high level this
paper
recognizes scenes of objects from single
pixels and it's best i show you
a picture of what's going on so you have
scenes like this where there is some
sort of an arrangement of
objects and there are multiple tasks you
can do here specifically they consider
the task
of unsupervised recognition of objects
which they call object discovery
and supervised classification of objects
the difficulty being that these are sets
of objects so there is no
ordering to the sets they
do this via a thing they call slot
attention
that basically is a permutation
invariant
attention mechanism over these objects
in both the
supervised ends unsupervised domain and
they do this in a fashion where they
iteratively route the attention
in order to make the different slots
compete for
attention over these objects so that's
the
sort of high level if you are in this
field you probably know
right now what's going on if you're not
um we'll dive into it together
so stay tuned if you like content like
this
consider sharing it out leaving a like
or
tell me what you think about it in the
comment i appreciate any suggestion
for making these videos better and
so people can learn more from it
all right so the problem i've already
described the
problem a little bit but let's go a bit
deeper here you have images like this
and the images we're considering are
going to be images that have some sort
of
arrangement of objects or what we humans
would call
objects in this case you can see there
is this gray
square not sorry this gray cube
right here there is a smaller green cube
and then there is a yellow cylinder
now in the task of object discovery
what you're supposed to do is you're
simply supposed to say
that there is an object right here there
is an object about
here and there is an object here
right so basically you're supposed to
point to the
pixels where there are objects
and you're supposed to segment the
objects from each other
you can see right here that this model
we don't know how it works yet but it
separates the the
left cube here the bottom cube here and
the
top right cylinder right here
in the task of set prediction
you're supposed to say what objects
there
are so you're supposed to say there is a
gray cube right here
a green cube right here and there is a
yellow cylinder right there actually you
don't have to say
where they are i guess there are many
different variants of this task
but mainly you're supposed to classify
them meaning you
have to say there is a gray
cube there i believe in this case it's
with coordinates
but you can do it without the difficulty
here of course being
that these are sets so there is no
natural order in it
so if you say there is a green cube and
a yellow cylinder it's going to be the
same as there is
a yellow cylinder and a green cube
um so you'll have to build an
architecture that is somehow invariant
with respect to the labels and
we've seen a lot of the concepts in this
video in this paper before
this video is sort of a a kind of a mash
together of different concepts
of other places so what you'll see
is for example this property of the fact
that
here you see are the labels for these
objects this could be
there is a green cube there is a gray
cube
and you'll have to come up with an
architecture that if
here you predict that green cube you
consider it correct
even though the corresponding label
isn't the one for the green cube
and we saw this for example in this detr
architecture by facebook
where they use a matching loss but we'll
get into that
okay so these are the tasks the tasker
object discovery
and set prediction so how does this
paper
deal with this they use this thing
called a
slot attention module now the slot
attention module
is in essence it's pretty simple what it
does is it has these different
slots right here as you can see
and it divides the input into
features so you can see there is a cnn
encoder because we're working with
pixels
it's natural that we want to encode
these into a cnn
this cnn will probably down sample the
image a bit
and divide subdivide it into this
grid right here so you have a fairly
coarse grit
the grid is actually not a bit finer
than you see here this is just
for example but you'll have ultimately
a number of features so each pixel right
here is going to be a feature
each feature will have not only this one
channel as you see here
but many many channels of information
down here so the cnn will encode each of
these
regions in the picture into a feature
vector
and then you have these slots so what
you'll want to do
we maybe look at this so you'll have the
features right here
these are your features and you'll have
the slots
and the slots let's say there are fewer
slots than features
two three three slots four slots
as in this case four slots
what you'll want to do is you'll want to
assign
the features to the slots so you maybe
say
okay this feature right here and this
feature right here
they go to this slot and then these two
features
go to this slot and this these two go to
this and that feature goes to that
and that's equivalent to basically
subdividing the picture
into these slots ultimately your goal is
going to be
to say that these features right here
these pixels right here sorry
are going maybe into that slot and then
these ones
right here are going into that slot
and these ones here going into that slot
and the rest so
all of their background is going into
that one you can see that if you have a
system like this
if you can train it correctly then it
becomes pretty easy too so it becomes
super easy to
classify it right here because you can
just take each slot and
independently classify it right because
you already know
you already have assigned all the pixels
where the object appears
into that slot uh you can just super
easily
predict a class from it so we're almost
at the end so
you now predict for each slot a class
or a description of the object whatever
you want to predict
and this is the exact same thing as in
this facebook paper now
where for each uh for each of these
slots we've predicted
a bounding box the question is how do
you
assign this to the labels and that's
pretty easy that there's this
thing called the hungarian matching
that basically what you're saying is you
want to be
as forthcoming as possible right so if
you predict
a gray cube somewhere and there is a
gray cube somewhere here
you want to match them you'll say okay
i'm going to give you the benefit of the
doubt and
i'm going to dear model
i'm going to assume with the gray cube
you meant that gray cube
right here and if there is the uh
yellow rectangle and the yellow
rectangle somewhere over there
you don't incur any penalty as long as
you predict the correctings
now only whenever you predict like a
second yellow rectangle so both of these
slots
now so this slot and this slot for some
reason they predict a yellow rectangle
this one correctly and this one was
assigned this
object and it incorrectly predicts a
yellow rectangle oh sorry
other way around this one incorrectly
predicts a yellow rectangle where
there's no second
yellow rectangle in our label set
there's only this uh
maybe this green cube then
this will be a mistake because it it
can't be matched it will be matched to
the one where it has the least loss but
it will be matched to something that's
not a yellow
rectangle and therefore that's going to
be a mistake
so this is how you calculate the loss
function with this matching
algorithm and you can calculate that
matching in a deterministic fashion so
you can back propagate through it so you
can see
if this slot assignment works we'll have
a pretty easy time
then calculating the classes coming up
with a loss the same for the
unsupervised object discovery what we'll
do
is we'll run these things through this
slot decoder now this slot decoder
is very similar to an a generator in
gans for example it takes a hidden
representation as
input now the hidden representation here
is going to be
these um these slots and it's going to
up sample it into an image if we train
the whole
if if we have a good slot assignment
mechanism
we can pretty easily train a decoder
like this
right with any method you want in this
case i believe they use
some yeah some sort of up sampling up
convolution architecture
right here and they use the l2
they minimize the reconstruction error
between
the end the output image and the
input image so it's sort of like a
variational auto encoder or just
auto encoder objective in this case
all right so we know how to encode a
picture
into hidden representation using a
standard convolutional neural network
and
we know once our slot attention
mechanism works we pretty much know
how to go from there so the question is
what is this slot attention
mechanism now what we're supposed to do
is we're supposed to again
assign each one of the features
into a slot and in a very specific
fashion so if you think about
the pixels right here there can be
multiple
of these pixels or multiple of the
regions multiple features can be
assigned to one slot
but we'd rather not have
mult the same feature assigned to
multiple slots so each slot
takes in many features but the features
should be
this divided between um
the slot such that only one slot attends
to a feature
and by me saying attend you probably
already know where this is going
so if you have the features
and you consider the slots right
and we just look at a single feature for
now what we'll do
is we'll have an attention mechanism
from the slots going
into the features so if you don't know
what an attention mechanism is
i have this video called attention is
all you need where i explain this
but briefly the features they will emit
something that's called a key which is a
vector and then the
slots will emit a query which are also
vectors and the
sorry the the
information is now routed by agreement
of
key and query in this case this thing
this
this feature right here would be routed
to this slot
now it would be routed to both slots but
it wouldn't be routed as much to the
bottom slot
and we make sure that this happens by
using a
soft max assignment so if this is like
nine and this is four what we'll do is a
soft max assignment such that after that
so
we have a proper distribution which
would be something like
after the softmax be something like 0.9
and 0.1
right here so you can see that the
attention is
fairly hard
so this is basically it's a
differentiable way to assign
these things okay so an attention
mechanism fulfills the property
that we want to basically assign
features to the slots in a way that the
slots
compete for the features as you can see
right here
if this slot here matches the feature
the best it com it out competes the
other slot because at the end
this has to be normalized to one because
of the softmax
so this competition is the heart of the
slot attention mechanism
and this is this is how it works
so this is the slot attention module as
you can see
so you'll take your inputs and they have
lots of layer norms in here but
disregard the
the layer norms so what you'll do
is you'll calculate the agreement
between the inputs and the slots now you
might wonder in a standard attention
mechanism
you'll have input signal coming from
here
which is like maybe these are the input
signals and then you construct the keys
and the queries for the next layer you
construct
all from that input signal right and
also the values by the way you construct
everything from that input signal but
in this case um we'll have many features
and we'll only have a fixed amount of
slots right here
so where do these slots come from where
do the the
signal for the keys come from in the
facebook detr paper we saw that these
are
learned embeddings however in this case
right here
these are not learned the slots are
initialized randomly so at the beginning
of each
thing the slots are initialized randomly
you can think of this as an attention
mechanism
where you have the attention module
right here
and then at the beginning you simply
have randomly initialized
uh positional embedding or randomly
initialized slots and then
the image is going to be encoded through
a
cnn right here giving you
a bunch of these features and then
you'll have cross
attention between these features and
this slots
and that will give you the next layer
right here
okay
all right so you want to calculate
the routing between the inputs and the
slots
and then you want to perform a soft max
over the slots
which will give you this competitive
nature between the slots so all the
slots are going to compete
for to to be route for the features to
be routed to
them and then this is simply the second
part of the attention mechanism
and so you'll have a weighted mean
now this is a slightly different from an
attention mechanism because in a real
attention mechanism you'll have a
weighted
sum right here here you'll have a
weighted mean but it's basically
such that you can have a different
amount of slots and
the kind of values will stay the same
that's why you do the mean so you
weight them up and the values are simply
a function of the
inputs this is like in a standard
attention mechanism
then what you'll do you can see
that this this is now called updates
okay so you start with the slots
randomly and then you tr you
use the slots to route the information
you take the inputs and you use that
information routing to calculate the
updates
now you put the updates through a
gru with the state being the previous
slots
and then you'll add that to the slots
either this says
optional residual mlp so what you can do
is you will
have a residual mlp or not
this is a fairly complicated thing
but if you think of it
it is just a transformer so what they
describe here
sorry the purpose of this gru here of
course is that
gru is a recurrent unit and you can see
right here that they do this
multiple times so once you start with
the random slots
right but then you update the slots and
you
go you go again okay
so you do this first of all you'll have
the features
and you'll just have random slots and
then you do a bit of routing
okay okay so now we have a bit of
routing cool
you update these slots to be the next
set of slots
and then you take the same features
and route them again so you you route
them again and
this is supposed to be kind of this
iterative procedure you might have seen
this in capsule networks i've done a
video on capsule networks
where exactly this type of iterative
routing you always have the same
routing functions right these the
functions for
value and qui key and query
are always the same um but you do this
iteratively many times in a row
this is like a transformer with weight
sharing
it's exactly the same right so you have
these slots you initialize them randomly
you do your query times keys
your soft max times the value right here
and this the transformer even has this
plus this mlp layer right here right
this
the transformer has that in there
and then you simply do it again
so up here you have the next transformer
layer but instead of being its own layer
you'll copy the so it's it's weight
shared
it's a transformer with weight sharing
between the modules
and the inputs they are also copied
up here this these side inputs
all right it's otherwise it's the it's
the same thing except that these aren't
produced by an
encoder that is also a transformer
they're actually produced by a cnn
and the weights here are shared the only
difference is that in between here
they also have like this gru this gru
thing
but they do an ablation on it and it's
actually not that important so you could
might as well just leave it away bring
it it brings only very
few benefits so this is how i want
how i think of this model this is a
multi-layer
a t-layer transformer with weight
sharing
in for the individual layers where
the inputs the input positional encoding
are randomly initialized each time
okay now they they really stress this
random initialization
because this differs from the detr paper
in that in the dtr paper these things
here are
learned and the dtr paper we have also
this kind of object detection thing
and it what will happen when you learn
these
is that for example this one right here
might specialize in
objects that are sort of on the top left
of the image
and this one might specialize in objects
that are kind of long and in the middle
and so on and this one might specialize
to something else
now i can't tell you what works better
or what not
it seems like um you can if i were to
implement something like this
i might want to go with the facebook one
and then just have
more right here in this paper they opt
for having fewer
but because they're fewer if you learn
them they become
i guess too specialized and you will
need to keep them agnostic
so you don't want to learn them you
simply want to randomly initialize them
each time and via via the iterative
routing
via the weight sharing they will be sort
of assigned
correctly all right
i hope you could follow this um
yeah if you if you want to
anthropomorphize this you could
think of each of these slots starts out
just randomly
and then just by sheer coincidence
through this attention mechanism they
happen to be
assigned a couple of these features now
because we train the model to perform
well
because they're already assigned these
features in the next layer they'll
basically
ask through the query function they'll
ask for more of that
they'll basically say oh i'm now
responsible kind of for the gray pixels
give me more of the gray pixels right
give me give me more
of that and then in the next layer even
more of that even more of that
and you'll see in the in the
investigations into what happens
exactly this type of thing happening so
if we skip ahead to the experiments
where they show what happens through the
iterations
you can see this right here so
the attention the attention maps of
these slots
you can see that in after the first step
you can see that you know it's slot 2
right here is assigned kind of these
both of these objects slot 3 is already
pretty so the the first step kind of
learns to segment a little bit of the
image but not
no too well slot for also the attention
map here is pretty
um pretty wonky but
if you in the next step uh and this is
kind of crucial basically the these
slots they specialize
so slot two realizes well i have a lot
of these uh these blue pixels so i'm
gonna give me more of those
right give me more of those so it gets
all the blue pixel well
slot four has a lot of these golden
pixels and says
give me more of that of those golden
stuff that's also
regionally right next to that and since
these two compete
i'm pretty sure slot 2 would also ask
for more of the golden pixels because it
has
a lot of golden pixels but it competes
with slot 4 because of the soft max
so all of the golden pixels are assigned
to slot 4
and not slot 2. while all of the blue
pixels
that slot 4 surely asks for as well are
assigned to
slot 2 in the next iteration so i
actually consider
iteration one is for you take the
randomly initialized slots and you kind
of assign them
stuff um so this is mainly the
this is now mainly the transformer layer
learning to segment
but then step two is where the magic
really happens
is where the slots they kind of realize
what's assigned to them and they ask for
more of it and through the competition
you'll get this separation into objects
right so the whole thing is trained end
to end which basically means that
these functions get really good at doing
this kind of segmentation
all right and then in subsequent
iterations you can just see this effect
uh multiplying even more and more right
but i might even you might even be able
to think that you might want to separate
step one and the subsequent steps
because step one
is sort of seems fundamentally different
from steps two three
four and so on uh because step one is
this kind of assignment process and then
the other steps are refinement so if i
were to
take this model and make it better i
would try
to have a special like not weight
sharing between steps
uh the first step and the subsequent
steps
but what do i know this apparently it
works uh
okay you can also look at the
reconstruction since their objective is
to reconstruct
um so basically what each slot outputs
each slot out if you reconstruct each
slot
here we these are the different slots
each slot is supposed to output a
picture
of of reconstruction now if we consider
that each slot is responsible for an
object you might very well say okay this
slot here gives me a picture
with just the object in it that it's
supposed to reconstruct
and then this slot here gives me a
picture with just the object
that it is supposed to reconstruct now
how do you know how to combine these
pictures
especially since they might be
overlapping and so on
so the way you do it is you actually
output four
channels so you output r g
b and a so a being the alpha channel so
each slot
also has to decide where the object is
that it reconstructs and so
each so this this here might be okay
everything here is alpha
one and including the shadow maybe maybe
there's a little shadow
and everything else is alpha zero
and then the alpha maps you combine also
vra softmax to ensure that they
sum up to one so you combine the
pictures uh
including their alpha maps but that
means you can basically reconstruct
from the slots um where
the where the objects are
now you'll know you'll notice this is
this thing here
you'll notice that they often use for
example here
four different slots because even though
the image has
three different objects why is that
because
you need to reconstruct the entire image
so
you need at least one slot for the
background
and that's always what you can see right
here
so if you have the uh sorry the
reconstruction you'll see that slot 2
with time with iterations it
reconstructs this cube
slot 3 reconstructs the little ball slot
4 reconstructs the yellow cylinder
and slot 1 reconstructs the background
okay also here if you see the attention
masks you see that um
the slot one will be responsible for the
background here the background is
significantly darker than in these
others
though they do say the background
doesn't really tend to
go to one slot in particular it tends to
kind of spread out across all the slots
and this might mean more investigation
um yeah so they have these different
tasks right here
for example to segment these tetris
blocks here
and you can see the segmentations
it works pretty pretty well now why does
this work so well
it's probably because of the data sets
so these kinds of data sets
they come you know they they're produced
by a generator and the generator
specifically has these
these objects right here and it sort of
in
it it arranges them in an independent
fashion the background is
really clean right the objects
themselves are really clean and
geometric
and so on and they're they're kind of
arranged in a random fashion
and then there's a render of that
so this is like super super duper clean
data set and
i guess that has a lot to do with why
these methods
work so well because they can just
assume
okay an object is generally you know
spatially
something some geometric shape that i
know it's close together it's pretty
independent from its surrounding
and it's trained with objects that are
almost
zero correlated like there's zero
correlation between
the objects in the training data set
so i wouldn't yet apply this much to
um to real-world problems but it is an
interesting thought uh right here
so that's the sort of idea behind the
paper i
hope you got that they do a lot of
experiments
and here is a bit where my quarrels
start so they say
that um they compare for example
with the with these in the
unsupervised object discovery
experiments
they have this data set called clever
and this data set
has these images with sort of uh
i believe clever six has all up to six
different objects
now this is already one of the things
this is not a specifically
quarrel with this model but if your data
set has six things they
all they give like they give seven slots
because they know
that the data set has at most six things
which means they can always cover all
the things now it works when there's
less subjects but
i think the knowledge of how many
objects there's gonna be
is also a big part of why these models
work
and why maybe it's not entirely ready
yet for the real world
but anyway they compare to these two
baselines
they're called iodine which also employs
kind of a recurrent architecture
but not with an attention mechanism and
monet
and they say um
yada yada this replaces slot no that's
not it
for the monet iodine dspn baselines we
compare with the publish
numbers as we use the same experimental
setup so they say they use the same
experimental setup
and that's why they don't re-implement
these models but they use the
published numbers in their respective
papers
which is something you can do this is
often
i guess these uh machine translation
papers and so on they do this
just because you know it's a lot to to
run these things
um however here i'm a bit skeptical
first
yes because it is it is google so they
do have a lot of
resources available to technically run
these things
i've seen at least monet has an
implementation by the author
or i've seen one of them the other one
also there is an implementation and
there's
eight authors on this particular paper
so
i yeah so i this would be okay
they say as we use the same experimental
setup so
in that case if you have the same setup
it's
more okay but it really depends on you
really having the same setup and
this is a bit where it kind of falls
so for example one example right here is
they say we train them using the atom
optimizer with a learning rate and 60 so
on they use a single gpu
we further make use of learning rate
warm up to prevent early saturation of
the attention
mechanism and an exponential decay decay
schedule in the learning rate which we
found to
reduce variance so i've checked these
other models and none of them talks
about learning rate warm up and nowhere
in their code is their learning rate
warm up now you might you might argue
okay
uh this is specific to this model it
might need this but if you look at the
results
right here for example you see that they
don't
outperform these other models by too
much so you can see
right here this is on par
this here outperforms this one a little
bit but then also
the star here means that they have left
out one of the
uh denotes that one outlier was excluded
from evaluation i guess which
is valid if it's a super outlier but
um in this case i would
categorize this model as a different way
of doing
doing things and not necessarily
outperforming
the others so this
also if you look at the ablations the
differences here are minuscule
and in these ablations that they show
every single thing they do like gives
them a little bit
of a boost and you just make it kind of
across the line to reach state of the
art
i'd rather have research move in a
direction where we just show cool ideas
and that they work and
that's what this paper does to to be
fair um
what i do have more of a problem with
a little bit is this here on clever six
we can use a batch size of up to 64 on a
single v100 gpu as opposed to
four in this iodine baseline right
compared to ion our model is
significantly more efficient in terms of
both memory consumption and runtime
which is you know something i believe um
but this characterization that they
use a batch size of four and
here in this paper they can use a size
up to 64 on a single v100 gpu i've
read the iodine paper and the iodine
paper
says yes they do use a batch size of
four
on one gpu so they also use one gpu
but they say their gpu has a
ram of 12 gigabytes and 12 gigabyte ram
gpus that points to something like a
ti either i guess a 1080 or a 20
20 80 or something like this this is not
a v100 the v100 come in
16 or probably google has the 32
gigabyte version
so this is a 32 gigabyte
gpu that is significantly better than
the ti gpus
these v100 they cost like five or ten
times more
than the ti gpus and to simply say
we have also one gpu and we can run up
to a batch size of 64 and they can only
run
a batch size of four it seems
i don't know it seems sort of
overstating
what you can do now maybe i'm wrong
maybe they have actually tested this
other model and concluded
also on their gpus it can only run to a
batch size
of in about as a batch size of four but
i highly doubt it
because in their here the paper is cited
and in their paper
they explicitly name that they use for
uh a batch size of four for their 12
gigabyte
gpus so
yeah in this that that just kind of
pulls through so there's the there's the
minuscule improvements
and then there is the ablations of all
these tricks where everyone just
gives you a little bit and then there is
this kind of very very very favorable
comparison word smithy a bit
um which gives a bit of a
uh a bitter taste to what i think
is actually a very very cool method
because
how why is this method so cool because
for example these
slots here they are trained uh to
also absorb the background right so you
can
technically at inference time increase
the number of slots even though you've
trained
uh with just with a few slots right you
can
you can increase the number of slots and
the model can just handle it and they
show it right here in these results
here you can
this data set has six objects and this
data set has 10 objects now the model
has only been trained ever on six
objects
and they can just up the number of slots
at inference time and it'll work
also very well also they can now up the
number of iterations since these are all
weight
shared these iterations right we've
looked at it there's there's weight
sharing between the iterations
there is nothing stopping you from just
piling on here because it's weight
shared you don't need any more
weights you can just refine this
iteration and since the iteration
themselves are
refining these attention masks anyway
you might as well at inference time
refine them some more
they have an ablation where they show
that technically like three
two or three iterations at training time
gives them the best result
i guess just because of gradient
propagation uh because more layers means
you have to
propagate the gradient uh back more but
at inference time you can just
up these iterations and as you can see
right here you get better and better
so this these results are are pretty
cool
and they respect the property that sets
should be permutation invariant
and and so on this routing view
of the transformer is pretty cool even
though it's
you can look at it as a transformer with
weight sharing or an iterative routing
protocol
like in capsules so all of this i i find
to be a very
very cool idea and i think that's how we
should look at this this paper so before
i am too critical of this paper i want
to say that i
really like the idea and
the algorithm here the implementation
yeah so that was the paper at last i
actually want to look at the
broader impact statement just because um
i've i've complained about broad the
need for broader impact statements so i
just want to kind of uh
go just read them and just like look how
how the different companies how the
different institutions how the different
people how the community
reacts to them crafts them and so on so
this one i find particularly
interesting let's go through it it says
the slot attention module allows to
learn
object centric representation from
perceptual input okay
as such it is a general module that can
be used in a wide range of domains and
applications
in our paper we only consider
artificially generated dataset under
well controlled settings
where slots are expected to specialize
to objects
however the specializations of our model
is implicit and fully driven by the
downstream task
we remark that as a concrete measure to
assess whether the module is specialized
in unwanted ways
one can visualize the attention mask to
understand how the input features
are distributed across the slots while
more
work is required to properly address the
usefulness
of the attention coefficients in
explaining the overall predictions of
the network
especially if the input features are not
human interpretable
we argue that they may serve as a step
towards more transparent
and interpretable predictions this is a
i mean it's a fine statement but it's
not a broader impact statement right
if you followed a bit what the broader
impact statement is supposed to be
this is not one okay the closest this
comes to a broader impact statement is
said
as such it is a general model it can be
used in a wide range of domains and
applications
and maybe a little bit that you can
visualize the attention masks to
understand how the input features are
distributed
but the broader impact statement is
supposed to give you
a preview of how this might affect
society at large
while this here just kind of lists
properties of the model
for the research community and sort of
for this
um for the application of this model
as as you know the introspection of the
model itself this
says nothing about uh society as such so
maybe
you know maybe that's i i think that the
smarter
people will turn the broader impact
statement
into more of an introduction section
because
that's something you usually put in a
conclusion or in an introduction
where you say look here are some things
our model can do and this is what it
might be useful for and this is how you
could introspect it
and so on and since the broader impact
statement especially at nurips you were
allowed to put the broader impact
statement on the main paper so not in
the appendix
but it wouldn't count towards your page
limit it's
i guess pretty foreseeable without what
people are
going to start to do is simply put more
of their paper
into the broader impact section kind of
cloaked in the veneer of a broader
impact statement
but i this is this is clearly
not what what the broader impact
statement
was originally supposed to be now i
don't know if this is good
or bad i just think these authors are
you know
they're doing i think the a good thing
here by simply telling us actually
something useful
about the model but that's just my
opinion i do thank you for
being with me here i know this was a bit
ranty
flip-flopping back and forth between the
different things we haven't looked at
set prediction at all we've only looked
at these kind of
masks but i invite you to go through the
paper yourself
and check it out it's pretty cool and
they do describe a lot of things in
pretty detail the appendix is very long
and has very
many ablations and this is something i
do appreciate
and with that bye bye and see you next
time